when you're away from your culture or
your country your family food is the
only things that connect you with that
warm gathering and ball of this rice is
sort of connect me this is my Persian
touch for Thanksgiving dinner
my name is nightmare bottom angle it
originally was born and raised in Iran I
learned cooking from my mother when I
was child she did not allow me in her
kitchen she said go to university get
your education when I was 18 I went to
for my undergraduate in graduate school
and after seven years I returned to Iran
and handed my master degree to my mother
and she allow me in her kitchen
for Iranians rice is always associate
with the celebration and no Persian
table is complete without it for
Thanksgiving I like to cook food rice
with saffron flavored golden crust
the ingredients in this dish is
barberries carrots oranges and pistachio
almond and of course rice and saffron
I have been an exiled you have this
yearning to connect yourself with your
past when I make this dish its heal me
comfort me look at this beautiful
festive dish and Lucy Joe
you